monsieur gros loi elle vient de dire
voilà je vous présente les abeilles
thomas professeur titulaire à l'école
durrmann d'urbanisme de l'université de
montréal bonsoir à d'actes menton soir
messieurs vous loi vient de dire ce sera
chacun décide et oui en partie mais
c'est au delà de ça j'ai des questions
de politiques publiques là dedans de
vision nos gouvernements doivent avoir
une vision sur le moyen terme
d'abord est-ce qu'on s'est traîné les
pieds depuis toutes ces inondations est
ce qu'on n'aurait pas dû agir plus vite
et plus fermement
écoutez c'est sûr que l'objectif
actuellement est absolument d'être assez
ferme
nous avons quand même une politique de
prévention une politique de protection
des rives du littoral et des plaines
inondables
depuis de nombreuses années et ce qui
est très important ça va être justement
de s'assurer que toutes les décisions
qui sont prises dans les jours qui
viennent mais aussi dans sur le moyen et
sur le long terme que ces décisions al
de l'avant et aussi en accord avec cette
politique et que cette fois nous n'ayons
pas de décret qui finalement permettent
de construire dans les zones à risque
justement expliquez moi parce qu'en 2011
après les inondations à saint-jean
richelieu on l'avait dit dans certaines
zones on ne reconstruit pas or on a voté
des décrets et le gouvernement charest a
permis la construction
c'est comme si on oublier vite cette
année en effet un problème majeur
et quand on a des politiques quand on
met en place des lois des règlements il
est très important de sur le court terme
encore une fois et ce sur le long terme
aussi pour avoir une équité au niveau de
la province du québec et d'équité au
niveau de nos collectivités
cette absence est complètement essentiel
de s'assurer que ces programmes ce soit
que c'est que ces programmes soient
fermes soient fermes en effet plus doit
bon pour ça ça suppose qu'on a une
meilleure cartographie ce n'est toujours
pas terminé l'exercice qu'on nous avait
promis il ya deux ans s'est lancé aux
mrc en partie bon c'est un peu complexe
mais bref on a du retard à prendre là on
a quand même tout un exercice
actuellement la communauté
métropolitaine de montréal la communauté
métropolitaine de québec
aussi certaines municipalités en effet
et mercier qui sont en train de faire
ses textes existent pour refaire les la
cartographie des zones inondables
ce qui est très important c'est aussi de
se rendre compte que c'est un
cartographie se fait en eau libre
or on a aussi des problèmes dans back
des problèmes de frasil on a aussi des
problèmes de nappes phréatiques
donc en fait tout de ruissellement dont
donc toute cette question finalement de
des inondations est extrêmement complexe
et ça peut aussi expliquer pourquoi ça
prend un petit peu de temps cela dit
d'ici 2020 on devrait quand même avoir
une cartographie actualisée dans cela
étant dit comme beaucoup de territoires
actuellement n'ont pas cette
cartographie c'est vrai que ça peut
complexifier un aménagement du
territoire résilient bon madame thomas
monsieur le goût vous l'avez entendu
depuis hier dit on va offrir à ceux qui
sont continuellement inondé la nièvre
année ou deux ans on va à frire
longtemps pour qu'ils se déplacent qu'il
parte mais on va faire d'autres choses
avec ses espaces là est ce que c'est la
bonne voie écoutez en effet on va dans
la bonne voie on va de l'avant on a
comme avec une certaine fermeté
on se rend compte aussi qu'on apporte
des incitatifs pour que les citoyens
puissent se déplacer
ensuite on voit aussi qu'il ya beaucoup
d'émotions vis-à-vis de certains
citoyens dans certains cas qui sont
quand même très attachés à leur terre et
à leur maison donc il va falloir que
cela s'accompagne de beaucoup d'être
dans les programmes pour que si les
citoyens prennent le temps de prendre
les bonnes décisions mais en effet là ce
que j'entends que ce soit à sainte-marie
encore à rigaud de réfléchir à
redévelopper les milieux hydriques en
ville à redévelopper des infrastructures
vertes pour justement absorber cette eau
on va vraiment de l'avant parce que aux
pays bas par exemple on a institué une
grande politique publique pour l'essai
la place aux rivières donc on a déplacé
des gens vous dites c'est ce qu'il faut
faire ici la refaire des parcs redonner
de la place à nos rivières qui explose
au printemps tout à fait mais en fait
aux pays-bas vous savez il y avait
vraiment un débat au début on a été plus
vers la résistance est à dire continuer
à construire des barrages continuer à
construire des digues et puis finalement
on s'est rendu compte qu'il fallait plus
réfléchir en termes de résilience et
donc de vivre avec l'eau de redonner de
la place à l'eau et finalement les pros
les les quartiers que cocon garde que
ces quartiers soient complètement adapté
à notre territoire ce qui permet
justement de construire des
collectivités résiliente sur le moyen et
sur le long terme
et ça ça demande forcément une vision
est intéressant parce que le maire de
gatineau pedneault jobin nous disait un
peu plus tôt en entrevue que lui avant
d'en arriver à la conclusion qu on doit
chasser des gens de pointe-gatineau par
exemple on doit tous faire techniquement
c'est à dire de l'endiguement peut-être
créer un nouveau code du bâtiment pour
rendre imperméable à ce que c'est comme
david contre goliath se battre contre
l'eau on va perdre on est mieux de lui
laisser la place à l'eau bah écoutez
c'est évident que c'est très important
de laisser de la place à l'eau et dans
certaines zones qui sont les zones les
plus à risque de permettre aux résidents
qui d'ailleurs souvent font le choix de
se déplacer parce qu'il se rend compte
que sur le moyen sur le long terme
c'est une situation qu'ils n'ont pas
envie de revivre ce sont quand même des
désastres au niveau individuel
maintenant ça n'empêche pas d'avoir une
réflexion sur des zones qui sont des
zones - risquent peut-être vincent ans
pour justement réfléchir à un urbanisme
à des codes à une adaptation du bâti
pour pouvoir garder c'est ces quartiers
parce qu'on ne sait pas que les
changements climatiques comment elle va
évoluer l'environnement
oui voilà donc les faire les deux en
parallèle mieux construire nos maisons
presque comme des bâtons et en même
temps de donner de la place à l'eau
isabelle thomas c'est le début d'une
longue conversation publique qu'on ne
rencontre des prochains mois merci et à
la prochaine
merci au revoir